we are doing a very simple goat draft
goats in a good way for a change
the best at their positions all time any
position you want to take that's what
we'll do peter you've got the trivia
question for me to determine the first
pick
i have the trivia question mike we
talked earlier about russell wilson
being a third round draft choice for the
seattle seahawks in 2012 and obviously
has gone on to an exemplary nfl career
in his nine years
so
i want you to tell me in that draft
there was a punter drafted before
russell wilson who was he
oh gosh i know i've known this for years
brian anger there it is brian anger
yeah
there was a pick made in anger by the
jacksonville jaguars
the jacksonville jaguars you could have
had
russell
wilson and you took
a punter whoever the gm was at the time
gets fired again
for that you get fired every year that
someone remembers that the jaguars took
a punter with russell wilson still on
the board all right goat drafts uh this
can go a lot of different ways because
there are a lot of goats at the various
positions i i got to go
because in my mind it's got to be the
separation the clear undisputed goat at
their position and for me it's got to be
lawrence taylor at the
edge rusher outside linebacker defensive
end whatever position you want to call
it best pass rusher of all time lawrence
taylor
final answer
yeah i like that one a lot mike i think
you're absolutely right i'm going to now
go to the quarterback position and i'm
going to take tom brady
um as i wrote my column the other day
you know joe montana and terry bradshaw
had won four super bowls
by the time they were 34 years old
tom brady
has won four super bowls since he was 37
and so i think what we're seeing in
brady is not only greatness at the
position and you could argue that
he's certainly not in terms of talent
the greatest talent that ever played
that position maybe he doesn't have the
arm of mourinho he doesn't have the you
know certainly he doesn't have the
quickness or of almost anyone
uh but i just think the entire package
the leadership package everything is
there and i'll take brady at quarterback
quick note on brady mds has argued in
the past that you could separate tom
brady's career at 2008 and he would get
in the hall of fame twice
pre
and post and maybe by the time he's done
in tampa you could have a third tom
brady bust for what he does with the
tampa bay buccaneers it really is
amazing the longevity and the
achievement and yes greatest quarterback
of all time tom brady next one for me
i'm gonna go
i got jerry rice as the top receiver of
all time and and it's strange every once
in a while randy moss pops off that he
was better and people sign on to that
look randy moss had the best skill set
the best god-given talent of any
receiver but he chose not to maximize it
he went to oakland and disappeared he
quit on his team too many times jerry
rice was always driven always motivated
always productive always working always
trying always effort and that's why he's
got all the records and that's why
they're not going to be broken and
that's why he's the goat at the position
he combined god-given ability with full
and complete dedication and effort and
maximize the ability he was given and
exceeded it so in my mind he's the best
receiver
i'm going to take a very slight detour
on this interesting little segment of
our show
and i'm going to say i would argue with
you and if you want to say that jerry
rice is the greatest of all time i'm not
going to say you're absolutely wrong but
i am going to say
that don hudson deserves to be in the
discussion
because when he retired from football in
1945
he had three times as many touchdowns
for three times as many receiving yards
with three times as many receptions
roughly as the number two guy in the
first 25 years of the nfl and obviously
it wasn't a passing league then but i
will just add this
he held for 44 years
the the receiving touchdowns record in
the nfl until steve largent broke it in
1989 so
i'm not going to argue with you but i am
going to say i don't think it's a slam
dunk um i'm going to go to offensive
tackle
and my offensive tackle would be anthony
munoz now truth and advertising here i
covered the cincinnati bengals in 1984
and one day i was walking by jim mc line
coach and in those days covering the nfl
was a much different animal
i walked by jim mcnally's office five
times a day when i was covering the
bengals i walked by every position
coach's office it was a little dumpy
building under a viaduct on the west
side of cincinnati and he called me in
he said peter come in here i want you to
look at this and he started showing me
some tape of the previous day's game
that the bengals played and he just said
i've just done something that i've never
done in my coaching career i have given
an offensive lineman a perfect grade
on every snap of this game
he excelled and never made one mistake
the entire game i've never seen it
before and i just look at that and i
look at the body of work
in a decade-plus career i think anthony
munoz the best tackle there ever was
every time i hear anthony munoz's name i
remember when he was you're early in his
career
john madden had not quite appreciated or
understood the nuances of the till day
and he called him manus repeatedly uh
anthony munoz played well enough that
everyone
everyone
sims has that issue with the pina colada
by the way he calls it the pina colada
but uh uh even when he's not here i
can't get him out of my head uh next i'm
gonna go barry sanders just because in
my mind barry sanders was the greatest
running back of all time he retired
prematurely he could have stayed longer
i know he would have had all the records
if he had he's still fourth all-time now
in rushing but uh just the the way he
moved the way he you know we've seen
tyree kill twist guys around
down field i mean that was barry sanders
all the time once he busted through the
line it was a man among boys even though
he was smaller than most of the guys who
were trying to tackle him peter
to me the ultimate man among boys is jim
brown at that position because you know
he's a 235 or whatever he was 230 pound
guy and so many of the linebackers he
was steamrolling were 230 pounds you
know whereas today it's a little bit
different devin white taking on you know
the more diminutive backs but
that one i would really disagree i would
definitely take jim brown over barry
sanders as much as you're right he is
the greatest uh in terms of change of
direction make people miss player not
just running back in nfl history
all right is that your last pick or you
got one is jim brown your pick that's it
oh are we going another one i thought we
were gone no okay i'm gonna go in the
third round
i'm sorry i'm gonna go to safety and i'm
gonna pick ronnie lot because not only
was he able to put the fear of god into
guys he was able also early in his
career to be a good cover corner i
thought he was a a safety for all
seasons
apologies to ray guy and adam vinatieri
i was thinking of you guys but it you
know you know sorry your punters and
kickers but still in my mind they're the
two best ever at those positions
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports